the thing about new brunswick is that
they are the only bilingual province in
canada and so
you know the rest of the provinces
they're
they're looking to see what what they're
going to do and so they have a bit of
a leadership role and so um i know that
a lot of academics are really up in arms
about them removing early early
immersion so it's going to be
interesting to see there are protests
there as well about what's going on in
the curriculum so i mean i think the
government and certainly from their
action plan for official languages they
know
that some things aren't going as well as
they would like they know that they're
trying to improve on that so i have
these reports and recommendations coming
through they just don't necessarily have
know how to to go about it and so
they're learning and hiring people like
you that are a bit more
perhaps well i think that uh
what we're doing is we're trying to
add a solution
to what's going on so what i wanted to
do is we've trained the teachers and i
really want to be able to train the
students so the teacher and the student
can meet in the middle that doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to take a
class but if you're someone who likes to
take classes i mean each person's
individual and you need to tailor your
language learning to yourself i'm really
want to do is offer you solutions to
your problems so you don't have to hit
those plateaus that you know you can't
really figure out how to get to the next
level so you'd have solutions to your
problems so you could really see how to
move from the beginner to advanced stage
and so i mean we're we're taking things
in
in a different way and so i mean the
technology that's out there is great now
and i like to kind of let people know
that there are different technologies
out there that they can't help them and
can be useful to them so it's like
anything you know you want if you want
to excel something you want to take
advice of people who have gone down the
road before you and then make it your
own and and hopefully add something to
it so
you know my view is that uh
and i'm probably a bit unorthodox here
but
as long as in the school system we're
trying to teach
quote the basics
or quote syntax
we will never succeed
in getting the students interested in
the language
what we should do is give them stories
to listen
and read
and let them enjoy the language
and let them if i think the technology
is such that it doesn't have to be with
our system but let them choose
make available available to them a range
of same things but always listen and
read never just read i mean you said
some people are visual some people are
everybody's both it really doesn't
matter the degree to which somebody is
more visual or somebody's more oral
everybody remembers better if they can
hear and see
so we should always have
in the classrooms stories that they can
listen to and that they can read and
then they need to work on vocabulary
and and if they work on vocabulary in an
intelligent way it means words and
phrases
not just individual words and learning
starting to see how the words come
together but not like i uh you know i
in my experience if there's if i have
one way of saying hello i'm happy
i don't need 10. when i'm further along
in the language if i start to pick up on
the fact that people say uh you know
how's it going okay
but initially i'm very happy with hello
that's all i would use
and if in a lot of the stuff that i was
listening to and i would choose what to
listen to based on what interested me
and if in there there was lots of how's
it going i start to at least get used to
the fact that people say how's it going
i'd probably be too timid to use it i
would still probably say hi
because it's short and easy
so i think there's too much of it and
the same is true of grammar
i think grammar the basis of grammar all
that's unnecessary
and the proof is that the overwhelming
majority of kids go through school
where the emphasis on is on learning
grammar and trying to get it right for
the test and they cannot speak the
language what is the possible point of
teaching people for ten
eight however many years the net result
is they cannot speak they might just as
well have been doing something else
that that's my views i'm a little bit
extreme on that but i think he's waiting
to differ just a little bit
i want to make sure that we're very
clear about
children learners and adult learners and
i'm here tonight to talk about adult
learners
okay anyways um
so
there are basically i mean i've been
marking the grade 12 french provincial
exams for the last eight years so i've
i've you know spent time listening to
the students in the level of language
they're coming out with and what's going
on in education in canada is the
pendulum has swung we've gone from
strict grammar instruction to getting
children to speak and what i would
suggest is that we need to meet
somewhere in the middle that knowing how
the language works and also practicing
it are kind of two components that need
to come together so there needs to be
kind of a balance between the two like
strict grammar instruction what we've
stopped doing with teaching for english
students the basics of english grammar
which is preventing students from
appreciating another language they don't
even have the basic kind of
understanding of how language work that
would allow them to
to move on another language so they're
looking to their second language to
understand their first language if they
had their first language down better it
would allow them to move forward more
quickly in another language
and so
i hate to use the word grammar because
it's being the way it's
it's it encompasses a lot bro the focus
is on syntax the syntax is sentence
structure and the vocabulary
those two run through those two skills
run through reading writing and
listening and speaking and so i've heard
students over and over they're
translating word for word and the
purpose of syntax and why i want to
stress it so much is because by knowing
syntax it allows you to think in the
language instead of translating word for
which is more cumbersome now that's not
to say that just strict grammar
instruction alone is gonna is gonna get
you there because you need to practice
you need to speak there are other skills
but combine them having an awareness
having a knowledge of of certain aspects
of grammar are really important in
moving you forward because it makes it
easier that
children if you look at them they have
to learn through trial and error so
they're picking up on repetition and
they're piecing the language together
for themselves if you take something
like a textbook they've already shown
you how the language comes together you
know by you can read about it and then
when you i mean you don't have to maybe
necessarily memorize it but if you're
hearing it you can already say oh i've
seen that i see how it works it's one
way to help you i'm not saying you have
to use that exclusively it's nice to
combine different techniques and methods
and technology and bring it all together
but do it to suit your own needs
just to comment on that i agree with you
on the repetition and i agree with you
that the child
has a very limited content that the
child hears many many times
and through a process of a year and a
half or two years of listening they
eventually start to be able to use the
words
so for the adult
uh we just have to do the same thing so
what i recommend i mean i deliberately
went out to learn russian
for the reason that i have always felt
that grammar was unhelpful in learning a
language because i simply couldn't
understand the explanations
now i have a lot in fact i even brought
with me some grammar books and i could
go at random and point to any
grammatical explanation in that book and
if i read it out loud it will sound like
nonsense
to most people it does to me not to a
grammar teacher but to most people it
sounds like nonsense
i couldn't cope with grammar so i said
russian is a very grammar heavy language
i'm going to learn russian so i went in
there and again when you read the
explanations of russian
i mean it it is if you think the french
or german is difficult russian you know
if they've got a different uh imperfect
verbs depending on whether you're going
once they're going and coming back or
whether you're going in a car but it's
just unbelievable and and you know the
singular and plural depending on this
it's in the genitive and sometimes it's
innovative and the endings all change is
hopeless there is no way through an
explanation of something that i have not
experienced it's totally meaningless to
me however what we do and what we
encourage when i started learning
russian i had a very simple story that i
had written in english for our english
learners i had it translated into
russian because
henry's colleague henry's gone now his
colleague is russian so he and his wife
translated it they recorded it i
listened to it 50 times so what you have
to do at the beginning is you have to do
a bit what the child did and so i said
to you if you can't hear the differences
in the tenses you should not be
listening to the radio you should be
listening to a limited amount of content
over and over and over it's a little bit
monotonous at first but it's just to get
you started so but so again my feeling
on that is repetition yes
grammar
i'm sorry me and and i think if the the
you say before we had more grammar but
people couldn't speak now we have less
grammar and people still can't speak now
we're going to go half grammar and have
something else people still won't be
able to speak
i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's doomed to failure in my
view